Do you know where Jackie is?
No. Let's find out where she is.
Okay. Let's go out and find her together.
Did you finish your math homework?
No, not yet.
I'm trying to solve some math problems.
But they are too difficult for me.
Let's find out how you can solve the problems.
There are many, many different places in the city.
A park, park, people come to a park to have fun.
A store, store, people come to a store to shop.
A zoo, zoo, people come to a zoo to see animals.
A skyscraper, skyscraper, people come to a skyscraper to work.
A stadium, stadium, players come to a stadium to play ball.
A garage, garage, people come to a garage to park cars.
People do many different things in many places in the city.